bruno le maire le ministre français de
l'économie et jean yves le drian le chef
de la diplomatie française qui viennent
donc de s'exprimer en direct de la cour
de l'elysée à l'elysée où se tenait au
tour d' emmanuel macron un nouveau
conseil de défense
sur la situation bien sûr en ukraine
nous sommes toujours en ligne avec notre
invité cyril brel je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialiste de la russie merci
d'être resté avec nous on l'entendait à
l'instant le bruno lemerle le disait un
nouveau paquet de sanctions a été
décidée emmanuel macron décidé
d'intensifier ses sanctions économiques
et financières
on retiendra notamment une des annonces
l'intégralité des avoirs de la banque
centrale russe ont été gelés la nuit
dernière
oui je retiens également cette mesure
qui est considérable
parce qu'elle elle n'est pas seulement
une mesure de rétorsion elle vise à
priver la russie des moyens de financer
son effort de guerre
qui est considérable et donc là la
mesure qui est prise n'est ni de l'ordre
symbolique ni du mythe de l'ordre de la
mesure de rétorsion mais bien de
paralysie de la chaîne de commandement
de chaîne de commandement russe on voit
que la france en particulier et les
européens en général
ont saisi cette occasion extrêmement
rapidement le rythme est beaucoup plus
rapide que celui des décisions
ordinairement prises par l'union
européenne et on réagit dans le domaine
qui est le leur l'humanitaire le
financier le budgétaire le juridique au
maximum de ce qu'il pouvait on est
vraiment maintenant au maximum des
sanctions possibles contre la russie est
contre ces cercles de décision afin de
juguler l offensive actuellement en
cours contre le les centres de décision
et créneau oui car jean yves le drian le
disait effectivement l'aide humanitaire
a été déclenché avec un mécanisme de
protection civile de l'union européenne
direction la pologne la moldavie
notamment et puis bien sûr l'union
européenne qui a décidé ce week-end
d'appuyer l'ukraine avec des moyens
défensif cela aussi c'est historique
l'envoi d'armes en ukraine pour aider
les ukrainiens à combattre l'ennemi
russe
oui c'est proprement historique
l'union européenne et les institutions
européennes n'ont jamais eu au cours de
leur histoire vocation à soutenir un
effort militaire les politiques de
défense les politiques d'armement les
interventions militaires sont encore du
ressort exclusif des des états membres
dans l'échelon national que cela se
décide et que union européenne octroient
des armements défensifs à l'ukraine
montrent l'exceptionnel de cette
situation il rappelle à quel point cette
crise est en train de faire franchir aux
européens en général et aux institutions
européennes en particulier une étape
décisive dans la maturation de leur
conscience géopolitique hier cette
guerre en ukraine a pris à un autre
tournant aussi avec cette menace de
vladimir poutine d'utiliser les forces
nucléaires la réponse des européens
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr cette
nouvelle sanction donc financière et
économique dont on vient de parler on ne
joue pas sur le même terrain mais
l'union européenne veut affirmer sa
fermeté oui et on a raison de ne pas
jouer sur dans le même terrain on
l'avait rappelé les autorités russes ont
tia soir mises en alerte et fait savoir
qu'elle avait mis en alerte leur unité
consacrée aux armements nucléaires c'est
un pas de plus vers la perspective d'un
potentiel usage de l'armé nucléaire
prendre des mesures dans ce domaine là
pour les européens auraient été alimenté
cette escalade faut bien voir
aujourd'hui qu'après cinq jours
d'offensive
conventionnel dans tous les domaines et
air terre mer et cyber les autorités
russes n'ont pas réussi à contrôler les
centres de commandement ukrainien la
résistance a été trop forte et que les
sanctions européennes sont en train de
paralyser les centres de commandement
russe c'est pour cette raison qu'il ya
cette montée aux extrêmes
l'annoncé d'une menace nucléaire qui
serait destinée à paralyser les efforts
européens donc les européens ont réagi
et je pense que il
ils ont eu raison de ne pas alimenter
l'escaladent vers l'utilisation de
l'armé nucléaire mais de rester
extrêmement ferme qu'un seul en sécurité
qui est directement en jeu merci
beaucoup cyril bret d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur france 24